Marty your new party's got itself into
terrible mess isn't it well I know about
that I think come the reality is four
million people voted for it last week
those people nearly all of them actually
had to make a change on where they'd
voted at the start of their lives and
that in itself reveals that they had to
make their mind up in a stronger way
than anyone who's let's say I'm a
teacher I bet labor I'm a small
businessman I go conservative which does
not require a great deal little
intellect nobody questions which way the
party heading now oh well I think the
there are two things here I mean the
Conservatives were very sensible to have
a 40-day campaign no one seems have
commented on it was a very good reason
for it because their treasures were who
insisted that they thought they were
going to have to fight a second election
within the next two years
the best way to put themselves in a
strong position if they weren't going to
get a majority was to force the other
parties to spend themselves to death and
forty days I mean some very generous he
might say it was a biblical inspiration
by the prime minister but I wouldn't
give him that credit this was a cunning
plan worked very well outcome of that is
the pressure during the election is huge
all parties on you Kip who have less
people less cash proportionally with the
number of seats they were actively
fighting remember we are the second
biggest party in 120 constituencies now
I think tenkan tempers afraid and people
worn out and I think they need to go
away for the summer and straighten
themselves up because I genuinely think
that I'm a I'm just a bog-standard
member yes I support them financially a
bit not very significant stairs leader
well the question I'd ask and I don't
want to appear as asking was answering
the question with the question is this
who was the alternative and right now in
the short term I think it was absolutely
correct for him to say he was going to
resign and he did resigned at which
point everyone turn around say okay he's
you you mr. Nuttall says I never cool
just well with the either the other
parties having little me but it appears
mr. Kazama is just said it there doesn't
appear to be the unhappiness which now
okay people are bleating about let's
let's ask press rattles gate I don't
think you'd regard yourself as a friend
of what you Kipp has become but do you
think mr. Farrar should go oh yes
certainly I think you should go as soon
as possible he's been in charge of the
party life for really 15 years one way
or another is unelectable he's
unelectable after 15 years if you can't
get yourself in MPs elected then you
really ought to do the decent thing and
go however he said turned the party into
a one-man band anyone who criticizes the
money a new CEO like will Gilpin the
former general secretary of the party
who says the part is unprofessional
anyone in criticizes has to go the
forces resigning cast into the outer
darkness also the way that the parties
run it doesn't seem to have a proper
constitutional structure it's really
just a kind of furor principal organized
around Nigel and it's unprofessional
also in its selection of candidates if
you look at the election campaign one
candidate want to murder his Tory rival
another one made of scene remarks about
album journalist six were caught by The
Mail on Sunday promoting neo-nazi
material on internet one good candidate
in the northwest of England the Scottish
surgeon resigned because of the ratio is
bullying and fills in the party when
you've got a record like that on
candidates you're obviously strafing the
bottom of the barrel so in terms of the
leadership the Constitution the
candidate selection and indeed policy
formulation all they could talk about ad
nauseam is immigration immigration
immigration immigration what's the cause
of the housing crisis immigration what's
the cause of transport immigration
what's it cause if anything's gone wrong
in the NHS or anything else it's
immigration this is mind boggling me
intellectually stupid I mean they
the party has got no mind it's not an
intellectual power force who can't
organize policies if you can't run a
party constitutionally if you made a
one-man band if your candidates a banal
beyond belief or even worse if your
policy is immigration or homophobia or
Islamophobia whatever then really the
party's in a digital mess so he's the
one that's presided over this he has to
go okay well let's put some of that to
Lord Hesketh I mean there is a point
isn't it with small parties when they
become big parties that sometimes they
do need to grow up and get proper
structures and that pattern Angela
Rogers Alice gets been saying is not the
man who's been capable of delivering
that organization well I I don't think
that's true so I think the scale is is
sort of picking up the detail I think
the the fact is that what Nigel Ferraris
real achievement is to turn it from
small party to a party which is nearly
three times bigger than the often thingy
that Patsy can't take it any further I
mean we had a health that's just kinda
not your question of my point is that
you have for example you are a mentioned
Paul Nuttall absolutely excellent
candidate I think the hell of this
problem really resolves around why on
earth did this happen within four days
of the election because actually I
didn't think he should resign there and
then we should have gone on there should
be in few minutes that's what he said he
wasn't I know that but as he did that
because he's a principled guy that's
part of the problem that you drive
yourself into a snowdrift and now we see
we outcome of that which is we're having
to call for snowplow we're going to have
to dig it out and waste quite a lot of
the parties time I mean I do have to say
to you I've spoken to other people who
work closely with Nigel Ferris and they
do say that the you know the bloke down
the pub is what the public gets but if
you work with him as a colleague he can
be vicious and thin-skinned and
aggressive well I can't think of a
politician very very few in my
experience or anything other than that
we badly want to say
I don't think what's new I'd say to that
one animal do you think there's a
personality problem with Nigel Farage
sure balance get yes I mean
he thinks he's God's gift of politics
where's the fact he's got lots of defect
defects he obviously drinks far too much
I always find him to be thick as a plank
intellectually and he's got no interest
in policymaking he just gets a few
points talks about that makes other
things up any party policy which the
party policy spokesman's developed he
just contradicts everything is just
Nigel I - he's a narcissist and he's a
very dangerous kind of blast uses for
the party because the party is getting
nowhere I mean it's getting all these
words but it can't win seats and it's
according to opinion polls it's the most
toxic brand in Britain 15 percent of the
electorate won't touch the party but
every bottle according to the pity
important my great fear is that it's
become so toxic because of its ratios
woman did sir homophobia and everything
else has become so toxic to the educated
middle class that when it comes to a
referendum they look at Nigel Farage's a
spokesman for the out campaign if the
media is stupid enough to make them that
but they look at him and say well if
this is a kind of person that's going to
run an independent Britain well frankly
I think we better off where we do better
off staying under Brussels so Toa final
word Lord has get that at keeping Nigel
Farage could cost only read write of it
the simple answer is Professor scale is
obviously representing some Calvinist
party I mean if we're reduced to saying
that he can't have a drink this is
ridiculous I mean one of his attractions
is he's a normal person he has a drink
he has a cigarette he has a joke he
believes in his country he believes it
should determine its future and rule
itself I mean I don't think that's a
very radical proposition but obviously
professor scouts thinks we haven't got
any policies which means Inverness is
further away than I thought okay well
I've leave it there thank you both very
much indeed